from the director of Chronicle and a
fantastic version of this movie you'll
probably never see and the studio that
already brought you two ridiculously
campy fantastic four movies comes a
reboot that's completely different yet
somehow still just as bad fan four stick
it's been 10 years since the last good
Fantastic Four movie now Fox must crank
out another one or lose the rights to a
studio that would do a much better job
so prepare for the obligatory trotting
out of Marvel's first family like you've
never seen them before Moody
awkward and really really low energy and
I'm here so you are
meet four people who are never referred
to as mr. fantastic the thing Invisible
Woman the Human Torch or the Fantastic
Four fantastic
civilian there's read the genius who
could bend his body into new and
exciting ethnicities been a big hearted
Rock monster whose superpower is not
having genitals this underused actress
in a terrible wig who's left behind to
make the guys uniforms I'm making the
environment suits and Johnny a street
racing brat cliche with the power to
ignite Internet comment sections for
being a black guy journey to the Baxter
Institute where kids create
billion-dollar inventions powerful
enough to destroy the world in exchange
for Pat's on the back you all deserve an
enormous pat on the back and wonder how
these child geniuses also managed to be
total idiots as they get wrong recruit
Reid's unqualified childhood friend who
gave them a screwdriver one-time
teleport to Mordor take some selfies
this one is definitely going on
Instagram and immediately stick their
hands in alien goo dude don't touch the
goo it's alien planet rule number one
tremble in anticipation for the return
of one of Marvel's greatest super
villains Doctor Doom then shake your
head in disappointment when you're stuck
with the super-powered sex doll instead
complete with vague abilities fake
motivations and fake Ghostbusters
references there is no Dana only Zuul
there is no Victor
who dr. toons the movie just when things
start to get interesting to deliver a
ridiculous finale where a villain who
can literally do anything with just his
mind loses two for inept teenagers whose
best strategy is to punch him in the
face so get ready for a superhero film
that's a shame to admit it's a superhero
film they're not powers they're
aggressively abnormal physical
conditions okay featuring some of
Hollywood's hottest young actors totally
phoning it in we're a team now and
there's four of us so we should come up
with a name for it clumsy references to
the comic books after doom over here hey
Auggie odd and bizarre shifts in time
that seem to mark exactly when the
studio took over from the director who
is to blame for the overwhelmingly
negative reviews for Fantastic Four well
director Josh Trank is saying not it
currently sitting at a nine percent with
critics on Rotten Tomatoes geez what a
mess the movie about making this movie
would be so much better than this movie
starring were you stretching or were you
dragging a wasted house of cards actor a
chocolate snowman Michael be glad you
don't have to do any more of these
another wasted house of cards actor and
crash-test-dummy Fantastic Four strike
three
man you know it's bad when Stanley won't
even make a cameo be sure to subscribe
for more honest trailers hey screen
junkies as a Thanksgiving thank you to
all our fans we are unlocking every show
on screen junkies Plus this weekend
starting at midnight on Wednesday
through Sunday that's right
you can gobble up every new show no
signup required click the link below to
get started and let us know what you
liked on Twitter using the hashtag
screen junkies + bib release quiz 'red
to infinity and Bed Bath & Beyond my
father gave me a small loan of a million
dollars I am Optimus Prime and I would
like an iced cot beer this time it's
personal